we had your friend here two weeks ago
jank we had him on yes my good buddy we
had him on we're like gilligan and the
skipper yeah so
i like how you slow play when you
talk about him very slowly but yes but
we but you you know the reason why i
bring that up is the following yeah
here's why i bring it up so
the question i got joe and i were
talking uh uh uh rogan and i were
talking over the weekend over the week
uh and you know i i look at politics
and i look at what's pulling what more
and who's winning okay
imagine the people on the right they're
like no you guys are going far too left
and the left is like no no you guys are
going far too right you got to come more
to the left right
okay so
jank goes from a say he's a republican
to an independent to a democrat to a
bernie
super left right that's what he goes i
have a very hard time
understanding that evolution that you go
that far left
as you age and his arguments are solid
arguments and some of the ones that he
makes for his side like okay fine that's
your argument i get it hey you know the
only mistake america made is when they
give 465 million dollars to elements
they should have bought a piece of the
company and had equity in it okay cool
so nationalized that's the argument
let's have more companies be owned by
the government and we regulate it and uh
they can't make more money i completely
disagree with the argument but i just
want to get your points
his method of making the argument i'll
say okay yeah i'll see how you're going
to it but who's winning today and
there's a question to everybody by the
way tyler think about this as well
tomorrow i'm coming to you as well
you've been around longer than we have
who's winning today is is the right
pulling people more to the right winning
today is the center holding this thing
are they being tipped to the left or
tilted to the right or is the left
winning more trying to drag people to
their side
go on it you want to hit that one i want
you to go first
yeah thank you very much for that i
appreciate that
um a little difference here you know age
before beauty is what he's trying to say
tom all right can i answer eventually
the um
so i look at a couple things and just
real real quick
i've been looking at um differentials
and voter registrations for the last
like three months and there is
you're seeing it in college students
you're nodding you know some of the data
i'm talking about i definitely know this
version it's about five percent
ahead for um
you know independents and republicans
right now versus dems and even if you
take the independence out which you
would understand why a lot of people are
jumping to the middle like that you
still have republicans are ahead on
voter registrations right now going into
the midterm election so i think that is
a sign of what's kind of winning as the
new voters are registering let me add
one thing on that which is the florida
numbers that you guys can check me as
i'm saying it so i get the numbers
roughly right but uh i heard desantis
say this last week that florida
basically before him
had a 200 000 deficit on the republican
side in terms of registered voters i
think they're up 80 000 now that's two
ways so
yeah so that's that's a huge we can
check the exact numbers but that's a
huge huge shift right there that so
that's one thing i would also say that
the you know the left right thing
sort of doesn't make sense anymore
because trump came in and crushed the
system to a point that people who were
traditionally conservative started
sounding like liberals liberals started
especially now sound like the craziest
authoritarians so left right doesn't
make sense to me anymore in the in the
specific sense i usually try to say
you're either authoritarian or
libertarian and what i mean by that is
you're not a libertarian meeting i'm a
card-carrying member of the libertarian
party and i run around naked on stage
you know demanding that nobody has
driver's licenses but you either believe
in individual liberty you can figure out
the best way to live your life and the
government should basically stay out of
the way and do some minimal stuff and
that's it or you believe in the machine
you believe that some machine if we just
gave it enough money and enough power
and enough purview over all of our
ability to think and act and everything
else that somehow us giving all of that
power to that thing could somehow govern
us better than we can actually govern
ourselves so that makes more sense to me
rather than left right or or democrat
versus republican because none of jfk
would be a republican now no question
about it he would be a republican he was
cutting taxes he was anti-war
right he he had he was a patriot um he
was hated by the machine and maybe the
machine killed if you talk to oliver
stone i mean you know
so so those the whole thing has shifted
in a really bizarre way but to answer
who's winning
um i think the right broadly if we're
just using the right left thing uh is is
really starting to win i think the woke
thing is so out of control the this
nonsense don't say gay stuff the
critical race stuff they're attacking
people's children now it was one thing
to lock people in their homes confuse
them about economics all of that stuff
but when you see cities burning and the
riots that we had by the way we don't
you know it's really odd since trump
left we don't have race riots anymore
it's almost as if there may be with some
coordination with someone yeah i know
this is alex jones a lot of stuff you
know um but i think they've gone so far
on everything so far in everything a
supreme court justice nominee can't say
what a woman is it's so bananas that i
think average people are just like i've
had enough of this and and what that
leaves you with is what i say on my show
all the time you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a democrat
i think that's basically where we're at
dave so for you when you talk about your
story and you're transitioning you talk
about sam harris and bill maher and ben
affleck so that's one of when they had
the muslim no you who are you are you
now the say all be all and you know
everything about this well i kind of am
over qualified to talk about this yeah
and then you say larry elder which you
and larry elder sat down so you know
there is a little bit of racism tell me
what tell me what tell me the data tell
me today there with this there was this
many fifteen thousand seven thousand
black on black tell me what they did and
you're like well you know but tell me
you asked the question you could so that
was an interesting moment and then you
also
in regards to the topic with atheists
you know while jordan peterson kind of
influenced you know maybe not being an
atheist okay so
we're all influenced by certain people
that change our beliefs all of us i am
you are well we all are
who influenced jenk when you saw the
process to go from republican to
independent to them to bernie how does
that influence take place so first let
me just say broadly speaking about jank
which i you know i don't really do i
really don't i'm happy to i said yeah
before we started you can talk about
absolutely anything it's totally fine
they've done a gajillion videos lying
about me and and maligning me and all
this stuff you can i've never done a
video about them period since i left not
one um so i just want to put that out
there it's just
because there's a little bit of
asymmetry it just doesn't matter to me i
i was part of something it didn't end
well i think seeing that sort of
hysteria and that that moment with sam
and everything it really did wake me up
so i'm grateful for that you know it's
one of those things i look back i don't
think that fondly of the whole
experience but man it woke me up and
life's been good since and i evolved and
that's all good so to answer your
question specifically by the time i got
there in 2013 he was already a lefty and
a bernie guy so i don't know that much
about his shift from republican or
conservative let's say in college to
what got him there but i think what you
said before is right it's really hard to
track a human being that goes in that
direction as they get older meaning most
people you become more conservative
meaning you start realizing that life is
sort of up to you that you know you that
you don't want that much interference in
your life all of those things and as a
businessman which i suppose he purports
to be a businessman i mean he's running
a network it really makes no sense
because you want low taxes so that you
can invest more i mean look look what
you guys have built freaking
extraordinary
so you would want all of the ideas that
i started to come around to the more
libertarian conservative ideas i just
started putting them into my life so
when larry elder smacked me around that
day that started a process even though
we were talking really about race it
started a process that got me
reading thomas soul books and then
ultimately interviewing thomas soul
which is probably the greatest thrill of
my career um it started it started a
process of opening myself up to these
ideas and then it and then the path is
kind of is kind of obvious you just go
down that path someone that goes the
other way
i just don't understand how you get
older and you're like no no the system
should do it more for us or no the
government needs more of our money or
any of those things i will say this
honestly i haven't watched a show of his
in years i don't know that he really
believes it in his heart of hearts i
don't yeah so i asked this question
because i'm wondering the only way i
think somebody goes further that side is
someone offended you okay someone
someone somewhere
and by the way listen reagan was
offended if you think about why reagan
reagan was partly if you really study
the story of reagan he was offended if
you study the history of and i know i
don't want to drop reagan and hitler the
same name hitler was offended you got
you know elizabeth warren was offended a
lot of people were offended like oh my
gosh i can't believe you did and then
you go do it but you don't necessarily
know if you're doing the right thing
just because the person that offended
you
so you're flipping no matter what that
offense could be a mom could be a dad
could be an ex could be a friend could
be a co-worker it could be a former
investor could be a lot of different
things
in that moment when you're offended i
think if you react too emotionally
you may all of a sudden pick up belief
systems that are not aligned with you
and then what oozes out is bitterness
and when bitterness oozes out i don't
want to
you know we have a hard time we all got
relatives when we're bitter at some
phase of our lives we've probably been
better it's like people are like listen
i just don't like to be around you
lately why because i don't know it feels
like everybody's upsetting you your
fusion so sure i'm like man am i really
like that bro it's hard to be around you
lately let's go okay cool well thank you
for telling me that and we kind of
figure out a way to improve because i do
think
jenk and i have never had dinner before
we've never gone out before we've never
done anything like that before uh we had
simply that was our first sit down we've
never hadn't had a conversation prior to
that um
i walked when i said
this is a this guy's got a great
processor he's very witty he's fast
he
he knows how to troll you and poke
because he's an expert at doing that
this guy uh uh i don't know if maybe he
needs to have the moment that maybe you
had i don't know
well i'm speculating but i actually
think you're making a great point on the
offense part and could something be so
personal that causes your whole way of
thinking to crack i think the sam moment
that you brought up i remember i mean i
was working there at the time and i was
having my wake-up call at that moment
when i saw that real-time moment like
that was all my frustrations with what
the left was becoming because i was
working for these guys and everybody
that disagreed with them was a racist
and a big in a homophobe and i was like
none of this makes sense it can't be
that we're all so right us lefties we're
so right about everything and not only
are we so right but everyone who we
disagree with is literally the worst
person in the world so that moment woke
me up and then you may have seen it sam
came to the studio oh yeah did this
three-hour conversation sam sits there
quietly calmness
you're saying yeah and jank is sweating
and the papers are flying all over the
place and there's a moment i think it's
that moment 19 if people want minute 19
if people want to see it where sam says
something about probability theory and
jank basically says i don't believe in
it
that's like saying you don't believe in
gravity i mean
it's real whether you believe it or not
it's it's happening right now but i
think yeah that thing kind of broke him
in in a bizarre way and that really was
that was the beginning of the end for me
that was in the fall of i think 2014 if
i'm not mistaken and i left in january
of 2015 because at that moment i was
like i can't work for this guy anymore i
just i was already shifting politically
but it's not easy to just give up your
job i wasn't making a lot of money but
it was like it was my job um but over
those months i was just like enough
enough so now can i say something that i
learned about because i haven't watched
uh the young turks in
years and years and years
um
that guy's an emotional dude yeah okay
and if there's anything that i've
learned from being you know sitting
right next to pat for the last few years
it's to try to try your best to be more
logical than emotional yeah and um
what we learned about number one i
thought he was a cool dude like i think
we could go have a beer with that guy
watch a sports game like actually kick
it with the guy would you disagree
there's a big difference between a
relationship like that until you make
the transition into money and boss i'm
not even taking the work around okay
like if we went to dinner and we watched
the game i think i
you know so i try because i'm
i've like the transition that you've
gone through dave yeah i'm going through
it i i know the story well i'm here to
finish the job
but a lot of it is you know logical and
stuff that you've been you know fed for
years and years and years it's not like
you know like candace owen she went
through something very similar the red
pill black all that i saw your interview
with her yeah but with jank
and here's something that he did that i
probably wouldn't have done two years
ago when we brought up trump trump's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and he got he got super
emotional and me
who traditionally would have been that
person two years ago
was like jank
just can i that wasn't his style two
years ago no yeah i was like jake are
you telling me that it's
like he's zero percent done anything
right like i'm at least willing to say
i'm not a trump guy at all but i'm at
least willing to give credit where
credit is due yeah and if there's things
that he's done that are that are good
that have helped
you know the country the the world
whatever i'm willing to do enough
there's things that are bad so it's
there's a lot of gray area there but to
be some completely black and white about
anything and to
what is it like to dig in and double
down
uh that's hard to do and then i'm kind
of kind of putting together your
timeline you know i said he's saying
he's a bernie guy
well bernie didn't really hit the
national scene until 2015 2016. you had
left by 2014 or something around there
yeah twenty two
he probably was
in his methodology at that point and
then boom bernie comes along in 2016.
and he becomes the largest bernie
advocate out there right you but also
the part of that that you gotta
understand is that then the woke part
got in too bernie was doing an economic
populist thing you could agree with it
or disagree with it i obviously disagree
with it although some of his the broad
high level points make some sense to me
but the policies of just taxation and
more for the government make no sense to
me but the deal with the devil that i
think the left has done is that they
took socialist economics and then they
combined it with woke with what is
cultural marxism this idea that your
your deficiencies or your immutable
characteristics or your whatever you
want to call it are the most important
thing about you so they combine
something that makes no sense and that's
why they're all so hysterical all the
time but i will tell you uh one thing on
the on the emotional side of this so
jank and i and a whole bunch of guys
that work for tyt used to play
basketball every sunday every sunday
from about seven a.m to noon five hours
nice busting our asses you got some game
day i'm pretty damn good i'm pretty damn
good actually you know what do you guys
play
he's very good come down i got a full
court at my house come down you gotta do
serious i i'm pulling i'm pulling
together a great game in miami anyway i
have a torn acl on my left knee though
so i got to play with one of those
freaking trap jaw braces sucks but all
right you and francis nagano both with
the tornado who was here yesterday
though ufc
champion of the world is that right i
did it believe it or not i did it the
last time i played with jank the last
time i played with jank i was going to
block a shot it was 10 to 10 games to
11.
it wasn't it wasn't win by two and a guy
had a breakaway and i blocked i did
block the shot but i came down tore my
acl that was five years ago anyway uh
but we played this game every sunday
busting our asses
i loved it i loved it more than anything
else like that's where i'm truly at my
happiest
and jank was the most emotional
screaming like the worst type of person
you would ever want to play basketball
every call that didn't go his way
screaming he'd kick the basketball
screen and i kid you not it was across
the street from a very very famous
church in la i'll tell you guys off off
the camera because i want to say exactly
where it was
and twice we played on sundays twice
police had to come to the court
to ask him to stop screaming
because people were going to church on
sunday mornings so that sort of tells
you what you need to know about the
overly emotional part of yes but it's
like it's like a seventh grader playing
basketball like you don't when you're an
adult and you're all out there like
trying to have fun and not basically
blow out our knee or break our neck
right stop screaming at everybody
what's the basketball court you're gonna
give it away
super super super competitive guy he's a
super competitive guy
and when you're super super competitive
you there's nobody if you don't take
control of that competitive spirit it's
gonna get the worst out of you you gotta
somehow take control of it uh and and
learn how to manage that energy but it
is what it is appreciate you for
bringing it up you're gonna like playing
with this guy because uh he was one cut
away from getting into the nba shaun c
phillips's nephew got the position over
him to get into the nba literally true
story wait this literally this is a
literal story he was on the i used to be
a baller yeah
chris humphries
when chris humphries married kim
kardashian he was one of the groomsmen
he was on yeah so he know he actually
he's the best jewish athlete in miami
that's all you need to know so i'll tell
you i can't do this one on camera either
but my house that i bought here was
owned by an nba player that's how that's
why i got this pretty sick court cool
he's probably going to know who it is
because he parties with all those guys
in miami so anyway you guys will hook up
afterwards and you guys will do that so
appreciate you for being a sport and
talking about it and i know sometimes
listen
four things four things you do in life
that changes the relationship and you
have to be mature to be able to manage
it one the moment you have sex with
somebody changes the relationship too
the moment you go into business with
somebody can be your best friend changes
a relationship three the moment you
travel with somebody and share rooms it
changes the relationship and four the
moment you pace somebody it changes the
relationship goes to another level tom
and i
we've traveled together god knows how
many years 15 years we've been traveling
together tom and i i need to point out
that we only checked off three of them
i had about 10 jokes rolling through my
head and
well done well anyway
okay so let's let's not that there's
anything wrong with that if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]